hello
mary control jib
hello
and welcome to the lobby uh gamespot's
weekly hangout every tuesday at 2pm
pacific right here on gamespot.com just
walks away jim's still moving still
moving yeah it's gone
uh it's our last show here on
uh floor three floor three yeah so we
decided let's break let's bring in the
big guns for the last show
now reminding us why we don't use the
gym anymore
you said you got it back you put it yeah
oh there you go look at this lovely set
and this is going to get torn up in a
mere minute yeah in about an hour's time
this is the fair well right yeah of the
set the lobbies we've got two more
lobbies left this year yeah we're going
to be taking a little bit of high hair a
little bit hiatus over january yep we'll
be back
next year but yes there's the last one
on this floor and this is the same floor
and the same set that on the spot yes
was done
uh
over there when when chris was hosting
all those years before that when rich
gallup was doing it was on this wall
here there's so much history gamespot
history
yeah yeah what is that like 15 years
worth probably yeah yeah easily we don't
care speaking of old things randolph
ramsay's on the couch what a segway
thank you for that you've got less great
hair than me you can't complain i do
you're here they just stand out more in
my hand oh that's true yeah it's because
it's gorgeous and dark like yeah don't
focus on it but anyway sorry you're here
yes because we've got you got a lot of
[ __ ] to do tomorrow we we do we do so
i'm here to talk about our game of the
year yes awards for 2015 uh which we are
kicking off officially uh today december
1st uh we've got actually a pretty big
significant change to how we used to do
things before so in the past you know we
used to do you know our platform
nominees we have a winner for each one
uh then we used to have you know a game
of the year nominees and a winner for
each one yes lots of repetition lots of
repetition across that at the end of the
day we kind of ended talking about the
same five or six games over and over
again last year was uh every topic ended
up being is a dragon age inquisition or
shadow of mordor that's right yeah and
in fact we kind of decided the is
platforms a kind of automatic not
automatically but there's an element of
like is that the de facto game of the
year now yeah exactly because if you
pick you know xbox one shadow of mordor
like all things being equal that should
be the best game on ps4 as well and on
pc as well right so anyway the change
we're making this year the big change
we're making this year is we're doing a
top 25 games of the year across all
across all platforms are going to count
it down from 25 to 1. um and you know in
that way we're able to talk about a lot
more games right so we were able to you
know highlight some of those um other
games that you know may not have been
the biggest triple a's or the ones that
you know we you and i happen to play a
lot in the office right so you know we
think it's actually going to you know
help give readers you know a broader
perspective on 2015 and all the great
games that were there we're not
completely abandoning platforms so you
know we're still going to have a you
know a best xbox one game yeah games
list where we're going to have five sort
of like finalists we're not going to
pick a winner okay so we're sort of
seeing those as you know like a buyer's
guard right these are the top five games
on this platform this platform that's
right and then you stick to the 25 to
one list to see which order you actually
should play those games so
all that stuff is kicking off uh the the
landing page for that it should be live
very shortly after the show yeah uh
finishes today the report cards are
starting this week the report card so
the first piece of content that we're
doing is a report card in all the major
consoles so we're kicking off with xbox
one had that did in 2015 and then we're
doing ps4 wii u and pc platform uh later
in the week early next week we're going
to do the year in review in news and
then from then on we're going to
actually start counting down our games
yeah loads of videos um and yeah looking
forward to 2016 then sort of the at the
tail end of our game of the year all
sorts of things and the and you know the
best things about this is all the
arguments not arguments sorry debates
civilized debates starting tomorrow
starting tomorrow we are all going to
sit down as a group at an editorial
group and fight
about what those games are actually
going to be this year's going to be so
hard because last year there was a lot
of you know there was a lot of
discussions over shadow of mordor and
yeah and dragon age man this year
you know what what do you have you have
just in the last few months fall out you
know you've got you know ac syndicate
over the last year you have you know
metal gear you know blood boards
which are three i know a lot of people
love rocket league yes as well so a lot
of rocket league glove here there is
going to be a lot of heat i think around
trying to figure out what order all
those great games especially because
there's 25 on the list now yeah it's
like you're going to tell me rocket
league's better is city skylines better
than that maybe not it could be a
headache tomorrow danny yeah i mean they
take it again look at a game like
destiny yeah that's even had a
resurgence in 2015. exactly i'm just
getting my early votes in i'm just
planting the seeds tomorrow you're like
you'll be excited tomorrow when you see
when you see that list of what we've
voted for so far we try and break it
down i think you'll find some surprises
there matt it's gonna be a nightmare uh
let us know what you think of course in
the chat and in the comments below what
is your favorite game of 2015 watch me
number one what's your number 25 as well
that's going to be super interesting
randy thank you so much for coming on
thank you appreciate it before you go
though we got a bunch of stuff on
today's show lots of reviews dropped
this year perhaps i guess the last
reviews of the year of 2015 at least
some of the bit the biggest ones so
we've got some of our game spot editors
on to talk about those but before we do
that we've also got a competition
running throughout the show and we
usually do we do a lot of competitions
on the lobby most of which aren't
actually happening during the show this
one is only for people watching live so
on the lower third there you can see
the fall of reach you can win
the fall of reach who knew accurate
hashtags tweet at gamespot with hashtag
the fall of reach for a chance to win we
have 10 of these i believe it's the
blu-ray of the fall of reach which is
available in stores and also i believe
online i think i've seen it when i was
browsing amazon during the week as well
it also includes a free halo digital
comic
inside so you can probably not actually
in there yeah digital comic like they
said digital it's probably pdf i don't
know maybe it's not maybe it's a bunch
of jpegs bmps i mean it's a blu-ray i
don't even care about it yeah they don't
compress it they don't care about that
yeah whatever it's a bunch of bmp files
yeah so make sure you get in on that
we're going to be we're not announcing
winners during the show but we'll be uh
people will be reaching out to your
social media for that uh so we'll be
back in a second scott butler is going
to join us to talk about rainbow six
siege but first of all let's check out a
trailer for that halo thing i was just
talking about
halo
you are hereby conscripted into unsc
special project codenamed orion2
destroyed the vostok arabian under a
minute with the best possible option
your only option
blue team is ready
hello welcome back to the lobby 2015 has
been a fantastic year for video games
and this week we've seen the launch of a
bunch of great games uh some of which we
have been playing in beta for what feels
like most of 2015. but yeah there have
been like i don't know like
seven 13 14 betas something like that
yeah one of which being rainbow six
siege
oh i meant four c's specifically sorry
yeah that was just siege there were like
you know twenty five or so six all the
betas right yeah that's the number
creeps up a little bit uh scott you
reviewed it or sorry you were in the
process of reviewing it for gamespot
yeah aaron of course we've had you on
loads over the years you've been playing
a bunch throughout the various alphas
and betas um scott first of all just uh
before we sort of get into the thick of
it uh we have a review and progress up
on the site now why is the full review
not on gamespot yet yeah well uh if
people follow the point which they
absolutely should
um you talked about embargoes just a
couple weeks ago and it was one of those
instances where ubisoft had said it
embargo of saying hey you know this is
when you can start posting impressions
and stuff like that and in situations
where we know we're going to want to
test the actual live servers and see i
mean cg is a multiplayer focused game it
exists online that is the way to play it
so unless we can confirm that it
actually like functions properly unlike
you know
good past example would be the master
chief collection that didn't work right
this time last year it was like three
weeks after the the launch of the game
and it's it was still not working yeah
so we want to avoid situations like that
so when there's an embargo and there's a
game that needs to be tested online we
will generally put up a review in
progress just to let people know hey
here's why we don't have a full review
if you're seeing it on other sites if
you're seeing other people post
impressions here's why we don't have a
full scored review we're waiting we're
testing things primarily the servers but
there are other factors as well like
pacing of the progression and other
things like that yeah uh aaron you were
going to say something oh i mean
typically when we go to review events
they set up an ideal situation where
you're all sitting in a room with
perfect servers and everything works
great yeah um
yeah i mean i've played rainbow six
siege today on both pc and ps4 and i've
actually encountered a lot of bugs that
i ran into in the beta
um like getting stuck crouching
and having to go prone to get out of it
and oh really rubber banding and like a
number of things that i'm not sure if
it's just a day one
launch issue but again like there's the
kinds of things that we didn't see at
the review event and today i've had a
lot of brokenness
that being said does it feel like it's
network
related
the game what the game communicates to
the player and i can't confirm this
entirely but i think it's hosted on
somebody's machine
so it's dependent probably on who the
connection to that person's a machine
being good so does it seem like some
games are running better than others
yeah it's very inconsistent like some
when everything works you know like on a
high level when everything works in
rainbow siege it's one of my favorite
games so far this year just because i
haven't had a game that's really got my
heart going like that in a long time
yeah like
the tension when it works is pretty
incredible
speaking quickly i guess just you've got
the it's like the most thankless job in
the world is reviewing especially a game
like this because not only do you have
to account for the quality of the game
and also its technical issues but you
can only ever witness your technical
issues i remember some people you know
post reviews of games and they don't
have like for instance we had jeff
grossman on the show for fallout a
couple of weeks ago who had really bad
problems on consoles i played 30 hours i
think or 20 hours maybe of 404 on ps4
hadn't encountered anything like he was
yeah so are you experiencing the same
stuff rnas is it no actually uh my
experience today at least has been
pretty smooth i've been playing on ps4
all morning um so i think aaron was
primarily experiencing issues on pc from
what he's told me so the getting stuck
bug was ps4 and the guy on the chat told
me how to get out of it so he he clearly
had the same problem
yeah i've absolutely ran into this
before in past reviews i can't think of
a good example off top my head but i've
definitely had encounter situations
where i wrote a review published it in
the comments what about this book what
up with this book and i'm like it's just
it never happened to me i don't know
what to tell you
so i am trying to be mindful of that i
am talking to other people about their
experiences with the game i am trying to
see how often those sorts of issues come
up how consistent they are for other
people i mean if it's just a one-off for
a single person maybe not worth
mentioning the review if it's something
that everyone besides me is experiencing
probably worth bringing up so we'll get
to that i guess in the review when it's
on gamespot i'm guessing later this week
sometime yes um hopefully end of day
wednesday maybe early thursday something
along that uh it depends on how quickly
i'm able to progress through the game
again progression is another thing that
i really want to test yeah it seems like
relatively slow to unlock new stuff
although i was originally told that you
could only play pvp after reaching a
certain level turns out there is
actually a casual pvp mode that's
available from the start so that's good
to know you can jump in and just play
online ranked pvp ranked is locked it's
like it's basically their hardcore mode
is what they're saying right um although
i haven't you have to eat food and sleep
properly
it does remove a lot of like uh in-game
help like you know in casual pvp you
have a grenade indicator like hey a
grenade just flew past you it'll be
blinking and let you know that you
should move yeah um but in ranked that
will not be there and there's other so
are they trying to like limit people
getting into ryan two don't you
shouldn't be in ranks the game has
basically the game can have a pretty
steep learning curve if you haven't
played the betas before it's a very
tactical game and like people have
played for a while are going to know a
lot more than you do yeah lots of
different characters lots of like nuance
yeah there's a lot to know like i think
their intention was to have you play
through their situations which is
basically like training that's enough to
get you up to five operators unlocked
and then of the 20 total of the 20 total
and then you can play terrorist hunt
that'll start getting your renowned
credits up that's the co-op single
player kind of correct yeah it's your
team versus a set number of ai um or
potentially an infinite number of ai if
you have to go in and disarm determine a
bomb so is that are those the two
single-player aspects of the game
there's the sort of the training uh
situation stuff and then there's the
terrorist on does that it's for sort of
ai single player yeah you can play
terrace on tenure on although it's
really designed for co-op the only truly
like single-player only portion of the
game are these situations which i mean
it it kind of borders on a campaign like
had there been more like directed
moments and and sort of
unique gameplay moments injected into
the experience and had there been more
story tying it all together it would
have basically been a campaign like it's
they're pretty robust for like just
calling them training missions kind of
undersells what they are well i know
it's a 60 game so you kind of think
let's have some it does feel like
there's a bit of an effect in here
it could have used a full campaign i
think they put a ton of effort into
making these operator videos for each
one of the operators cut scenes which
you're gonna watch one time it feels
like if they just put that energy into
making cutscenes for the situations
they would have had a campaign yeah
right and like there's there's the
there's a germ of a story in it i mean
the intro to the game like the cutscene
you watch when you first put the disc in
talks about basically the creation of
the rainbow six like what rainbow six is
if nobody remembers yes this was
originally a tom clancy novel like there
is actually like a universe here that
you could draw from to create an actual
story and the opening cutscene hints at
that but then the wrestling game doesn't
really touch on it it's like you could
have like there was room for a narrative
you could have done some stuff and but
then again you know who knows plenty of
people who play call of duty like i
haven't played single player in years
exactly so it's like where do you focus
your resources so let's talk about the
actual multiplayer itself yeah let's
talk about the shooting what are the
modes how does it play does it have
longevity so the most important thing to
know about siege especially the pvp is
it's very
kind of unforgiving it's it's set up in
a very deliberate manner it's
there are no respawns you've won life
per round that's it it's no more than
five versus five um so it's it's a very
controlled and particular setup there is
no straight like run and gun respawn
team deathmatch it's more of a counter
strike than a call of duty it's it's
even more tactical than counter strike i
mean it's very deliberately paced i mean
every round actually opens with a sort
of planning phase where defenders will
be able to set up traps and sort of
fortify their position and attackers
will be able to use remote control
drones to scout out and find objectives
and aaron and i have been talking about
how crucial that phase is i mean it
sounds a little dry like oh you're
driving your drone around you going to
you know mark your enemies and all that
kind of stuff but seriously it's such a
crucial time saver if you know where
your objective is before a round starts
you're not kind of running around
aimlessly you can actually plan with
your teammates what you're going to do
and how you're going to infiltrate one
of the things it's very tactical one of
the things that will give this game
longevity i think is just the variety of
stuff that can happen in a round right
yeah for starters there's a lot of maps
there was a ton of maps that we didn't
even see at the review event and that's
fantastic i'm going to be talking like
15. it was pretty much every almost
every map from the situation i've seen
so many minimum 10 it seemed like there
might be i think it's all the maps
you've seen in beta plus maps from
situations and then each one of those
maps has multiple locations multiple
times of day right and then just like
tactics will switch you know we
we played against a team where they just
love to like lay down in corners and we
figure that out yeah and then they had
to like switch up their whole their
whole tactics
that's the great thing it's all about
moves and counter moves like once you
figure out your opponent's strategy you
can react to it and they have to react
to a reaction right and it's great that
it actually allows for that kind of
creativity and strategic depth i mean
it's not just if you just run into a
room and try to gun people down you're
probably going to die um and it's so
great that there's again room for
creativity and also mind games and
things like that like you can bust out
boards and you know you can fortify a
door and if you bust out one board you
can potentially trick the other team
into thinking that you're just crouched
waiting for them and use it as a
distraction or you can like set up a
breach charge on a door you're not
actually going through and then detonate
it remotely and come in another way
there are all these different techniques
that you can employ to give yourself an
advantage and it's great that you're
given the tools and given the
opportunity to actually do all that
stuff rather than just again mindlessly
run a gun the game also has something
that is so neglected in so many
multiplayer games which is mixed mode
servers right like mixed mode
just adds so much longevity you don't
know which you're not you don't know if
you're going to be defending a bomb
attacking a bomb a hostage like yeah
you're right that is weirdly falling
falling out of vogue in the basket like
again battlefront was a perfect game
where like battlefront threw everything
against the wall in terms of modes but
then they didn't have a mixed mode
server so every like four maps you just
got bored and had to go search for
something else to do by having mixed
modes in this it just adds so much
variety to what you're doing and the
operators and all the gadgets as well so
each of the 20 operators has a unique uh
item or ability that they can use and
that helps to create variety as well
especially since you have to unlock them
and it does feel kind of earned when you
have to pick and choose and very
gradually earn new new characters and
new abilities okay my last question on
this because it sort of comes into the
you know when people are asking is this
game i want to play you know this the
amount of single player stuff
multiplayer itself is obviously
important another thing especially
multiplayer shooters is is this the type
of game where you really should be
playing with four of your friends or is
it fun enough playing with random that's
part of what we're figuring out i mean i
was talking to somebody earlier today
like i don't think you can hold a game
accountable for its audience and you
can't be like oh the player base sucks
therefore the game is bad but but if
your game is enjoyable if a game is
built to be team based it is the game's
job to
equip players with the tools they need
to effectively communicate to educate
players how to use those and to
incentivize or entice that type of
gameplay i mean if you're built to be a
team placed
team-based game you need to
make players play that way give them a
reason to play the way and give them the
ability to play that way like it may be
a simple version of it but you can
imagine a version of rocket league for
instance which didn't
educate the player in those ways needed
uh via like the chat stuff and via just
like you know the way
the way you you can center the ball and
that becomes like a focus like that type
of thing is crucial to a game being fun
especially with playing a random people
right the best experience is definitely
going to be on mic with a good team or
just at minimum on mic simply because
there's things that you can't
communicate such as reinforce this wall
like i put armor over here hey don't
don't blow up that wall we need it or
don't reinforce that wall we need it
yeah it's very contextual these are
things that the game doesn't have tools
for you to communicate without just
getting on voice chat so
you know finding a good group of people
like when you when you
play with good people just you know
friend up with them yeah and that'll be
the best because you know it makes a
huge difference to the people you're
playing with and i i so far i've had
pretty good experiences and again you
can't necessarily hold the game
responsible for that but if you have the
option to play people you know or at
least people who care have microphones
do it the game is way better when you
have those people playing with you
excellent scott and aaron thank you so
much for coming on get out there and
keep playing maureen we succeed because
we need to get that review up on the
side yeah best of luck with that and
thanks so much for coming on and talking
about it of course uh let us know what
you think of rainbow six siege have you
been playing the beta are you playing on
pc or on the console let us know in the
comment box below alright we'll be back
in a second we got bunch more video
games that came out this week to talk
about but first of all here is a trailer
for europa universalis4 it's the
cossacks
defenders this is alex polefco i've got
the rundown on the loot and survive
patch for dungeon defenders 2 on ps4
wipe again is coming you have to make
sure to check out how to get rewards for
playing before the wipe on
dungeondefenders.com
in onslaught mode you'll have to survive
wave upon wave of enemies to earn unique
rewards
once you hit level 40 you'll unlock
nightmare modes one through four it's a
pretty intense challenge you'll need
some good loot
we've made some improvements to the hero
deck and you can now get your heroes to
level 50 and in the campaign we've added
a bunch of cool mini bosses
there are two new costumes for the month
the tiguaro monk with some sweet
upgrades and cat monk and if you're
looking for something new for your
apprentice check out the farm boy
apprentice costume
he took no shave november pretty
seriously
there's a monthly and daily mission
system and this month is actually my
favorite uh pet reward it's the gato
thundero
and speaking of pets there are these
awesome activatable abilities
where if you evolve your pet you can see
what ability it has and then use r1 and
hit x to activate the ability concerning
loot we've done a complete stat revamp
for the game we've moved some chord
stats like defense speed to passives and
added new core stats like defense
critical hit and defense critical damage
rarities like epic and legendary are
actually rarities now and not tiers so
we really need to hunt that 850
legendary
thanks for checking in defenders be sure
to go to dungeondefenders.com for the
patch notes and more information on
whiteboard
and i think europa game really looks
like dungeon defenders i did not expect
it to look like that
who knew
who knew
that is not the fourth
europa
europa universalis at all that's dungeon
defenders uh there is a launch trader
for european reversals for the cossacks
on gamespot.com so if you want to go
check that out
knock yourself back
peter brown's here what up you've been
playing a video game
for
extended periods of time in the game
spot office for the past number of weeks
the review is finally out
uh
for folks in north america that can
finally play what's the game zander
blade chronicles x yes yeah or cross
xenoblade chronicles cross xenoblade
xenoblade nathan haywand 8 out of 10 on
gamespot.com tell us about it what's uh
what's what's what what did you enjoy
out of all of the hours you played how
many hours did you play actually first
of all uh 65 okay
and there is a lot more to see in the
game i mean it is
well for one it takes place in a massive
world that's got about five continents
that are like
we say games are big these days this is
really really big like i could spend
hours on a single continent and remember
i'm only looking at 20 of this game
right now yeah
um but in that space it also has a lot
of quests and a lot of opportunities to
to earn new gear make friends and
ultimately you unlock massive mechs that
transform into this vehicle you see on
screen right now
and uh i mean it is a huge game that is
a
it's a technical masterpiece
especially on the wii u but even i think
you know if you look at other games and
other consoles it's impressive how this
manages to have such a big world let's
talk about i guess the earlier parts of
the game because from what i was talking
to you last week this very much seemed
like the mech of something that you
reached after say 50 hours or 40 hours
of the game it's not quite that bad okay
but yeah your first 30 hours are spent
on foot as a human you know you are a a
guy or a girl and you team up with three
other soldiers and uh and you
essentially you're trying to explore
this this planet that you've crashed
landed on
you don't know what's out there and
you're trying to find a thing that will
ensure your survival
and in doing so you encounter gigantic
monsters and
and things like that and it's a really
wonderful like ah surprising experience
yeah
i will get to him in a second okay
elton john so i mean this is really a
game about exploration and combat and it
has many many layers of systems and
subsystems in it
uh and unfortunately at the start a lot
of the
like how those things work together is
pretty ambiguous the game will introduce
a concept and then just sort of leave
you to go do whatever you wanted to do
without really giving you
many examples of how it works now i'm
not saying that it necessarily needs a
tutorial to explain everything but i had
to go to the in-game digital manual to
figure out a lot of stuff right it's
very difficult to
to understand the intricacies of
everything involved in this game is that
the sort of thing where if you had
played previous games you might have a a
tighter handle on or is it well maybe
but i played 100 hours of xenoblade
chronicles on wii and even then i was
lost because there are so many things
that are brand new here uh so many
little things that have to do with
gear and skills and sort of managing
your relationships to the military that
you're a part of and working with the
different divisions inside of it i mean
there's there's a lot to juggle lots of
different quests there's obviously the
main quest stuff there's all this like
affinity side character-based quests as
well yeah and this was something that
was a huge part of the last game but uh
so yeah you have main quests you have
side quests which are just simple you
walk up to someone they give you a quest
but these affinity missions as they're
known are used to sort of form a web of
relationships
and how you manage those relationships
can influence how other missions open or
how certain people react in certain
situations i found
because you have to find someone
in the right location at the right time
of day to even get the mission right and
then they have all these prerequisites
and they tell you to go to places that
you've never heard of like there's a big
base that you have to explore and
you know out of necessity you go to some
places curiosity will take you to other
places but if you're busy in the field
fighting because that's what you want to
do you're not going to know where to
find derrick in the commercial district
at noon i mean it it sort of it leaves
that up so affinity missions are a good
idea that i think don't work as well as
they should right but yeah the side
quest stuff and and exploration in
general and most of the story missions
are really
good they
they encourage you to explore that
exploration is great uh what's the
combat like i know a lot of the game is
about exploration but ultimately it's
also about shooting stuff uh lots of
crazy beasts and whatnot on this world
yeah i mean this is this game captures
what it's like to be in a prehistoric
environment better than any game i've
played um uh so yeah you played orion
dino beat dan no i guess i i'm not
prepared to speak about it
yeah so
a team of up to four characters and you
only control one at a time it's a
real-time combat system
you have one range to one melee weapon
and you can choose from a few different
classes that specialize in different
types of offense and defense
and you know you don't have to play as
the main character the avatar you create
you can play
the supporting characters as well if you
choose but you can only have one at a
time and you have to sort of reorganize
the party uh one problem i do have with
combat while it is really exciting and
can be really great uh healing is
something that
is i think too complex where in most
rpgs you either have a healer class or
someone who can
at least use consumable items to heal
you
in this game you rely on a system known
as soul voices so let's say my health
drops below 20
i can then set something to happen when
that condition is met maybe it's healing
maybe it's something else so at that
level that makes sense but the game
throws a quick time event at you right
in those instances and you have to react
very quickly in most cases
and
healing isn't always something that you
have total control of
which i don't really love
but um
you know it sort of punishes you at the
most difficult parts of the game well
it's tough to say because there were
plenty of opportunities where i was fine
with it rarely i felt like
man i hope something happens that can
heal me you know it could have been a
common battle where i just slipped up it
could have been a big battle
it didn't define the combat experience
but it was one of those things where if
i had my way i would have used a potion
and just healed myself immediately and
some of the best stuff we're seeing here
is with the uh or most interesting
footage-wise is this awesome mech uh
transforming into uh i guess what looks
like a motorbike or whatever talk about
that what does does that change the game
fundamentally is there much like
diversity in terms of the types of mechs
that you can
hold off okay so like i was saying the
game is gigantic think bigger than any
game you've played before and you're a
human right then all of a sudden you are
in a 40-foot robot you know the giant
odd like deer dinosaur that was towering
above you you now look in the eye i mean
it changes your relationship to space
and in that way time if the two are
relative as you're going about this
world and trying to
find things discover new places engage
with enemies that initially you looked
at as nope i'll never be able to fight
that in my life but wow it's crazy now
you can say i'm gonna go kill it and see
what it drops wow um and and that's
great and you can have a team of up to
four mechs are pretty expensive uh in
the game you have a good way to earn
money by exploring and planting these
things that mine the earth and you can
set up that system it's really complex
and so you can afford more skills as
they're called and uh scales skills
scales they were called dolls in japan
but i guess that didn't translate
from enough well you know who wants to
say dolls i don't know
i feel like if you're already deep into
playing xenoblade yeah who cares if
you're a penny and for a pound yeah uh i
mean
mechs are one of the few things that are
just amazing about this game and it's
gorgeous for a week that's what i'm
saying
yeah but like there's a certain art
style which
seems to lend itself on wii u and it's
not this no but this looks pretty great
actually it's great yeah um and you know
again getting your mechs so late you've
become so comfortable in your
relationship as just being a small
person that when you get this it is just
like i'm in a whole new game like this
just feels all brand new and they they
have like
15 pieces of gear that you can like you
know upgrade change mod add augments to
like all this great stuff um it's it's
for someone who loves details and
tinkering
there's no shortage of stuff to do great
little surprise for the wii u the end of
2015 it seemed like a sort of a solid
stardom medium and it seemed to be
floundering there for a while we've had
a couple of you know between mario
tennis and yeah amiibo festival and and
maybe yoshi as well it hasn't been super
super strong uh this is a nice kind of
ending to 2015 for the week this and
super mario maker are the best things to
come out of nintendo in the past few
months
awesome peter brown thank you so much
for coming on thank you so much for
playing xenoblade like you know the
thankless job of being reviews editor
for a big website and also trying to
like wrangle game of the year stuff and
then you have to play 65 hours of this
game on top of it it was a privilege
like xenoblade chronicles is an amazing
game that i've that i i hope people buy
we use to play because i want to i want
to play the next xenoblade but i also
have like 200 hours left to spend with
this game so yeah great well okay you go
and do that uh in a second and uh thanks
so much for coming on uh let us know
what you think in the comments below if
you've been playing as xenoblade
chronicles x or cross whichever way you
wanted zeno zeno
i'm not here to judge let us know do you
think of that game are you finally going
to buy a wii u hey all you tens of
millions
do it you're one of the only other
consoles anyway right maybe not the xbox
one do it
do you want an xbox one
no yeah see
laughs i have access to one though
you've access to one yeah i have access
to a
to these nuts what what mary kiss
oh wait was that mike who said that yeah
they sound very similar yes sir yeah
thoughts and tones mary cage and we're
going crazy here because it's the last
day of the lobby on this beautiful
beautiful set uh hopefully hopefully i
get this trailer right
ed sheeran
the video game it's guitar hero
baby i'm electrical
the way
engaged
i mean
of all the game of all the trailers for
it to end up being
it had to be [ __ ] rock band it
couldn't have just been like
pewdiepie's game
it's unfortunate for you i don't know
we're all pretty busy this week
the running order is haunted this week
it says different games than what the
trailers are
we'll just put it down to
gaming to your craziness
and video game awards craziness and psx
is on this weekend and moving and moving
floors
is a payday and is it payday beers on
thursday yes we're probably going to
need that
yeah uh if you don't know already we're
tearing down the lobby set after this
including our beautiful um
signature wall which is never in shot so
it was we did a great job there you guys
yeah look you can just see
mixed written above your head
right there sid meier's name that's the
only one that's ever in shot right we're
gonna do a little tour of the lobby set
uh when we're uh just at the end of the
show before we
finish up and break this thing down but
first of all mike mccarty yo what's
going on i just uh finished playing just
cause 3 for a while you did you played
it for a bunch yeah uh you've played it
all last week you played it during the
weekend i see you're still playing it uh
you've
reviewed it for gamespot.com as well
eight out of ten rico right three guys
is back and still a bunch of fun it
sounds yeah it's not too different from
one and two if you've played both of
those there are like people were asking
me if it's necessary to play both of
those i don't think so at all for the
wonderful backstory yeah
there's a
rich lore yeah um rich laura himself
isn't it no um but there are callbacks
to like returning characters and
obviously rico himself yeah i could i've
competed both games could not tell you
one other character that's in those old
games oh i just finished the game for
like 35 hours a night
rico's in it that's the beauty of of
their you know having so much time pass
between this and just cause two was it
like 2009 i want to say or something
maybe eight pretty far maybe eight maybe
that far better great games so
what's similar what will fans of the
series uh experience in just called
three that they're used to i'm guessing
you liberate a lot of settlements yeah
it's very much still just a sandbox in
every you know every way
it's good start you can fly jets into
statues you can
you know hijack jets you can fly
helicopters into buildings and then wing
suit out and
tether another helicopter to the ground
and pull it in uh rico can take a fall
as well i believe oh yeah um i
fell from about 550
kill most people
um it would and then but you a lot of
times you get shot too much obviously
you're going to die but he still can
take a lot of damage which is good i
appreciate that because i don't really
want to die in this game i want to blow
things up and it's not it's not like
it's actually not as thoughtless as it
looks uh like rob and i rob was playing
a lot doing all our video work for it
and he caught the video review and he
was
you know like i was going through the
story missions i think rob largely
ignored those and just pretty much opted
to experiment with the tether and
everything and he was doing some crazy
[ __ ] that i wouldn't even even thought
of which is the great thing about this
game let's talk about that then for a
second so the the obviously we're used
to him being able to jump from vehicle
to vehicle that used to be the sort of
the bid and just cause now you can
tether uh objects together and sort of
retract them and that you've got
the mines can be upgraded to have
rockets put on them and stuff like that
do you use that in combat much
uh you yeah the tether definitely i mean
when you first get it you can tether
like if an enemy's shooting at you
because in this game guns are actually
like the most boring way to fight people
but you can tether someone to the ground
behind them and then
pull them and or just pull two guys into
each other pull an explosive barrel into
someone so it's really helpful in the
heat of the moment i think i resorted to
guns but the game is really fun when you
can just kind of plan something out and
put mines all over the base before they
know you're there and then fly out and
start grenade launching them from the
parachute and then detonate everything
and then watch people go flying all over
the place it's also fun to hijack butts
yeah uh hijack them or put the rocket
things i mean you're hijacking in one
way or another aren't you
you're claiming it for your own when you
say when you launch someone in space by
wow their butt cheeks you know if they
said that in the game i'm not sure it
would have passed its zeros or b rating
uh probably not no do you know if you
buy this game you stand a chance of
winning an island what that's on the
cover of the box really purchase this
game for a chance to win an island it's
not hard is it
no it better not be doing that that'd be
i'm gonna write a letter i don't think
so yeah it's probably like something
somewhere in fiji some kid in montana
just wins ireland
and then he's in charge doesn't look
anything like this either it's raining
the whole time uh peter what is it about
like just cause one and two came out
they were sort of on the you know that
whole xbox 360 open world game um like
the dawn of that sort of that genre
really exploding like we had games like
gta but you know off the back of this
and infamous and crack down and like
we're just so used to them now like the
open world is just it's not even a genre
it's just the way games are what do you
think it is about just cause three which
is essentially a it looks
rather like just cause two and one um
that makes it still so appealing because
people are so looking forward to this
like we see it in the comments you see
it all over the online forums and
twitter like people are so looking
forward to this what what do you think
it is about just cause traded this has
this lasting appeal it goes back to what
mike was describing right there are so
many tools that expand your
possibilities to do and experience new
things and very few limitations upon
those those tools and it's you know the
fact that you can
create a series of events that chain
together so perfectly and that it works
so well without
any like
air of seriousness i mean this is
ridiculous and they've unlocked all this
ridiculousness and that works so well
where so many games take themselves very
seriously and perhaps say no we don't
want you to do this or we don't want you
to do that just you can blow up anything
you can blow up anybody you can make
them blow up into each other like it
it's just amazing to me how far you can
go in this game before you hit a wall
that is like that's not possible yeah
okay yeah it's like their line for for
what's acceptable or possible is pretty
far yeah and they've totally upgraded
the extent of your capabilities look at
this nonsense i know like there was a
there was a jeep tethered to that jet
that was rob also right i believe at one
stage rob uh i like the idea yeah
tethering a helicopter to the ground uh
he picked up a ruckus or sorry he picked
up a tank and then dropped the tank out
of the air jumped out of his plane into
the tank and then drove the tank around
the base and then blew up the tank after
he was done yeah he attached the rocket
mines previously all right before
everything and then used it to detonate
it yeah let's talk about where this game
falls short i guess which is sort of you
were alluding to the fact that rob
basically didn't do much of the campaign
stories because he wasn't really into it
in your review as well you weren't too
hot on the campaign yeah i mean i wasn't
expecting a great story and i don't hold
it against them the story serves its
purpose they say like go blow up these
rebel bases and then they add on like
we'll rebuild whatever we need to so
that's pretty much just saying rico
there's no such thing as collateral
damage just go do whatever you want so
let's just rebuild all those people
right and those
like two billion dollar
that whole continent pretty much and
that's actually not that expensive of a
continent but it's not a continent it's
an island right it's not go crazy
they're not giving away a continent on
the box yeah i know that'd be crazy
because then hope it's not europe
yeah but yeah it's
it's just but these the actual gameplay
of the scripted missions themselves
which are they're not essential to
playing you could avoid them but in
order to yeah in order to unlock certain
abilities and certain vehicles you do
right um you would still have fun
without doing it but those really were
very repetitive they're all they're
always they're a lot of escort missions
and the ai companions like obviously we
all have escort missions as it is yeah
but no i'm kidding but the ai companions
themselves are pretty um inconsistent
they'll sometimes die right away the
checkpoints will have you they'll reload
you at previous checkpoints after
someone just screwed something up that
was clearly not your fault right
frustrating um i guess lastly let's talk
about there's been a bit of a blowback
today on the internet about performance
which always tends to be um
we can't really tell if there's a lot of
people experience it or not me and rob
did a gamespot plays earlier today and
we got some frame rate hitching on the
pc but he hadn't really optimized the
settings for it uh what did you play
this on and did you find any sort of
graphical stuff it's a bit of a
powerhouse right right um i played about
30 hours on pc and then i played another
between like two and four on both xbox
one and ps4 consoles are noticed uh pc
is noticeably better
the frame rate dipped a lot more on
consoles it was nothing that would
actually have affected my score on
individual platforms but
it was less
of a frequent issue on pc because pc
looks it's a really good looking game
especially when you're over the water
and everything
but every once in a while on all
platforms um the scripted missions again
would not trigger correctly so you have
to like steal this tank at one point but
the boat itself
and it wasn't like the part of the
script the boat itself just would be
floating away as you're trying to drive
on to it and then the next time it'd be
fine but then i went to play it again on
ps4 the same thing happened wow okay and
consistent bugs yeah and that's that's
like uh
kind of a bummer because a lot of the
reason i was looking forward to this
aside from the fact that it was another
excuse to play a just cause game is
because as opposed this is like the ps4
the xbox one as opposed to the xbox 360.
so like the technical less of like
technical limitations was a big draw
yeah for me with this because i was like
well what now what can i do that we have
this much more capability
knows what the modders are going to do
on pc as well yeah i'm looking forward
to it just cause 3 and 2016 is going to
be super dumb peter brown mike mccartney
thank you so much for coming on talking
about that video game uh is that the
last big release of 2015 then in terms
of the review team rainbow six siege
uh scott's working on that yeah and i
think that's the last you know big game
of the season uh yeah but dude it's
gearing up again in february with an
onslaught of stuff yeah a lot of stuff
remember because this week is crazy yeah
and we're also concentrating on 2015
with our game of the year coverage as
well yeah yeah it's gonna be nuts uh let
us know what you think of just cause
three are you excited to play it on pc
are you gonna pick it up on console uh
let us know uh if you think it's maybe a
late contender for those game of the
year awards as well maybe creep on in
there put your thoughts in the comment
box below
all right we're almost done here i want
to remind people that we have this uh so
i don't know where halo reach has gone i
think or fall of reach really we're not
giving away halo reach don't worry
that's
that's not what's happening here uh yeah
quick reminder to everyone who's
watching live uh right now you can win
uh one of ten blu-rays of halo the fall
of reach uh which we're giving away here
includes a free digital comic who knows
what formats it's in only ten of you
will ever figure it out hashtag the fall
of reach uh make sure you tweet at
gamespot
while the show's on so you've only got
about five minutes left before you can
get a chance to do that and you can win
one of these these where's that green
screen thing on actually these it's gone
is it gone has disappeared peter look
behind you is there a dumb thing nope
there's not wait there's no dumbbells
mike no
where's the grid there i want to see it
joshua put all this effort into this hot
technology
where is this behind peter peter it's
there oh it's over here yeah pick it up
pick it up and show the folks
oh look at it oh look that's great look
at that
rotating
technology
that's actually pretty impressive that's
pretty good i go like this oh sick can
we put something real dumb up there
uh something dumb quick something make
me look dumb dumber than i already look
oh my god i can't believe oprah winfrey
is on the lobby with us right now
i can't believe you're here
oprah and you're a square
peter you're going to have to do an open
voice no upper goes can't believe
you're here
yeah sure
oprah winfrey
is that rocket league cat
is that right yeah do it perfect
i'm just trying to salvage the situation
it's great you're looking great oprah i
especially like that white bar always
one white bar
jesus how long have we had that thing
it's too long too long we've never used
it
okay this is the thing can i stop being
a cat you can stop being a cat now um
but the cat will do it should we do a
little tour we do a little tour
of the of the set we're gonna
jesus christ
it's terrifying uh we're done here on
the lobby set almost recording some
videos
make sure i put this on probably
not sure if they can hear me where you
guys could just stay there yeah because
you're tethered because we only have one
wireless mic
so you can just
hang out here do a little tour andy
bowman he's got a steadicam in the
background what's going on
uh yeah we're ripping this bad boy off
actually first of all andy turn the hell
around uh because this is the old set
this is the million dollar wait is
warren going are you sawing it
we're in dog
we're in a coffee here how are you doing
buddy oh gee games i remember watching
you uh on uh old on the spot when rich
was hosting and you're naming the
credits yeah yeah
which was uh yeah exactly
which was a course over on the main set
uh you you designed you built our i did
with the help of mary and neon and
everybody yeah yeah yeah the old sets
try to put it together yeah maybe give
us a hand with the new one as well yeah
maybe downstairs uh were you part of
when they built this one yeah as well
this thing cost a million bucks i heard
at least at least
so these things apparently are like it's
the squares are so that the computer can
track the
the sort of the seed the motion yeah
because it was chris used to host here
on a desk but it was like a digital
set which is pretty crazy the virtual
set yeah so they kept the wall up but we
haven't used it
not in my time anyway this is where we
record obviously a bunch of the old um
game spot plays and mary doing her crazy
uh horror streams and whatnot uh and
then this thing over here
this bad boy how long has it been here
now mary
just like it's like two years maybe
i think the boys are sitting there
this is uh i'm not sure can we even see
behind this thing we can't take it down
there because we're doing one more video
on it this is the best thing on the set
by the way
kingpin life of crime
uh i think this is dan mchork's poster
it's like the dumbest thing ever it
doesn't have anything to do with the
game and behind this wall actually can
we actually go around can we go around
it's all fake it's all fake just what
no we can't kick it we're doing one more
video
did anthony
roman built this yes anthony built that
uh who's our the dude who does all the
brilliant um thumbnails and graphics on
gamespot uh he built this we put all
this dumb stuff in here we've got some
hot big rigs over the road racing here
of course i tried to make one oh really
did ryan try one and it didn't work out
this is all just free tasks we get i'll
especially like this weird
see-through
[ __ ] big boss i think that is that
looks like snake eater oh no yeah i
don't know maybe it's uh maybe it's five
did big boss have an eye patch and snake
eater
did he have his eye he didn't all right
that's probably five then
dovahkiin the world's worst fallout
thing
it's 50 bucks and it feels like it uh we
had to pick all these games for for what
we wanted to
to go here so it's actually a pretty
good collection of
games these are all empty we have them
all the library um i'm not sure if we're
keeping any of these actually uh xbox
with some xbox one stuff in here we got
some psp games we got
we actually i think we made a point of
getting all like 10 10 out of 10's game
spot did over the year in here tony hawk
pro skater 3 is here half-life 2 is
there i didn't get 10 out of 10 i got
9.6 now world of warcraft's here another
10 out of 10 on game spot all those hot
swat four
andy baumann knows it's that hot video
game you need to play
uh we've also got cain and lynch i think
in here as well all those hot references
yoshi's here this thing never really
came together the way we wanted to that
was the mistake the heads because
predator was put on and i was like he's
not really a video game thing but that
was a bad idea yeah
a bad idea we never took down
uh
we got
this is i keep forgetting he's here and
it wasn't until we got the vault boy one
that i was like oh yeah bethesda like
has this ridiculous budget of sending
massive statues to like everyone and
every game spawn or game stop in the
country i did it god damn it
and then the last one
warren you did this
this is your work
signature no not your signature
uh the signature wall all of uh game
developers uh and and internet peoples
uh something's already falling apart as
the whole building's going vince sampela
so this if you want to steal anyone's
identity uh for any uh developers that's
vincent palas uh peter molyneux here
we've got nathan vela who apparently is
a garbage gamer i don't know who wrote
that
eric pope i think did bless you mary uh
gabe miller the il-2 stermovic guys
decided to this is what they did this
when there was like no
names on it at all they just decided to
write hardcore with passion across the
whole thing um
you have some great stuff here alex
jabali uh
keith lee yes of course hashtag sickly
ups was that sean
sean mcinnis when he left yeah when he
went up to seattle we let him write
something and of course he tainted the
wall theresa daringer i think has done
the best one here for canon brawl that's
pretty good uh greg miller of course uh
or a friend of the site counter spy iron
bread
uh
who combo fiend combo fiends there
up there i love dp john carnage from
twitch
john vignacky wrote it there uh
sid meier
just hanging out there with mike bithell
all those great ones oh my goodness here
we go there's that og
what's up let's gamespot old [ __ ]
where'd you find that
uh remember that big noise you heard
just a second ago yeah that was me
getting it from the other side of this
wall is there any of that old stuff
still there yeah there's like oh we
should i mean don't know what you guys
got but like because this used to be oh
yeah there used to be this curving wall
that was the set of on the spot is it
still behind there yeah okay
let's kick that we can't kick the order
we got one more video to do
you guys having fun yeah yeah you do
have the moss yeah i think it has
masters that from a call of duty stream
we did
all this [ __ ] this is the same this is
out oh yeah you guys never get to see
this this is the
production room what's up what's up eric
taylor you gotta increase your range
apparently oh really yeah they want you
be able to go around i think we're come
over come over come over
what we got back here is this the wall
oh yeah look at this
we might need some lights back here
it's got this on it now because we they
sometimes get these like decals or
whatever and like paint over the the top
of them something they have we're doing
our last uh tour of the old set
um batman
was this what this was this is the
batman thing oh so it wasn't call of
duty
yeah so this is the old set this is the
old on this bottom it's just hanging out
in the back
uh
what are these things jesus christ
there's so much stuff here uh yeah so
it's all getting torn down i'm not
taking any of this stuff outside of this
world
israel can you see any of this here
logos back here oh my god videogames.com
that used to be like a window
like a fake window type thing all right
this is see-through
you can light it in the back
videogames.com
right there and this awful sombra thing
down the horse
dan
person who's worked here longer than 540
club
sure as well
how long you been working here uh nine
and a half years the thankless job
setting
yeah destiny hats yeah
uh yeah you were working when this was
when this set was being used
oh really this came in new york this
whole set lights up on the bottom all
plugs in
uh we were used to replace all of these
banners we had uh tournament tv oh yeah
we had fun mashing button mashing both
one and two
uh we had today on the spot we had
gamespot sync
on the spot again yeah
we had
videogames.com see that's this is the
only thing that has videogames.com is
it's the only one yeah and all this is
getting tossed uh i'm keeping this
keeping this they're putting it up in
your bathroom
yeah should we bring it on set
what's this what is this
that's brian ekberg's hat oh is it
really weird in the rafters when he
stopped
oh no would you just pull it down yeah
oh yeah it smells like it's been in the
rafters shout out to brian ekberg we'll
see if forts of motorsport six oh my god
ben ben's leaving with the only
this is a leftover from uh e3 2008 down
in santa monica oh gods yeah 2007 2007
the weird one that was on the boardwalk
when they tried to downsize e3 yeah this
has been in my office
it was in justin calvert's office
and that was in my office and now it's
going to whoever wants it
how much luck do we have for oh is alma
here
is alma here
by the way just so people don't talk
when we're straight when we're actually
broadcasting we have alma
um here what's your surname again fettel
paxton
mother daughter mother not daughter in
in in fear first encounter assault recon
uh yeah so that's we put alma there so
nobody nobody [ __ ] with us what you
what you got you got oh
can i can i drag it over this logo bar
on the wall it's so dumb it's so insane
it's like
all right let's go back in let's go back
in come on everybody
i wonder if my computer is still hanging
out back here
yeah you there
you guys are such good dudes just no
you're not oh you are here i don't know
sorry i should have moved that
sweet
what a video game adventure what else is
here look at this
oh jesus
oh my god
what did you find
all right i guess that's uh that's it
for live shows from here the third floor
on a cbs sized building um the time
trotters room we also didn't get to see
that's somewhere else and we didn't get
to say hi to everyone who is in the
who's working hard at the moment we've
got all the game of the year stuff
happening this week
you crazy kids um we're almost done
we've got one more video to shoot here
after the show we're gonna get a bunch
of uh the report cards for various
consoles up on the site in the next
coming days uh but yeah from everyone
here uh for whose new faces and old
faces and middle faces and foreign faces
and faces you don't get to see which is
mary in the background who does so much
work to do the show every single week
fabulous job josh and josh where's josh
go see josh go wave with josh josh never
gets do anything he's probably playing
rocket league
let's do it
there he is joshua
master director
do some do some hot directing
yeah
josh you can hear josh but what he wants
you to know is destiny sucks
and
rocket league is the best game of the
year
we can do it all right that's the show
everyone thanks so much for everyone
who's been watching and gaming spot here
on the third floor we'll be back in 2016
with more hot live video game coverage
on a new floor and a new set so uh until
then uh stick around for all our game of
the year stuff and uh we will see you
yeah there i got a sick transition did
it go we almost don't fade to black all
right we'll see you in 2016.
you